so in this video i'll move on to
probabilistic reachability for
dtmcs so this is uh so
probabilistic reachability is a
fundamental property of
select dtmcs and it corresponds to the
problem when starting from some state
it's the probability of of the path
reaching some target set of states which
we'll call
t and we'll use the notation p of s t
to be the probability when starting from
state s
we reach the target t and when i want a
vector over all states i'll just use the
notation
p t and this can be used for example
if i wanted to know the probability that
that algorithm terminates
successfully so here the target would be
the
states where the algorithm has indeed
terminated
successfully or we could find it like
the probability that an error
so occurs during execution this is just
so the probability of reaching the
target where the target is
is the set of error states so
just to say that there's a dual notion
of
invariance so this is the probability
that we remain in
some class of select states so again
when starting from some
state and this we can compute from
reachability probabilities
so the probability that we remain in
some set i
in the invariant set i this is equal to
one minus
the probability that we leave the
invariant set
so we reach some state outside of i
and this can be used for example to
compute the probability that an error
never
slight occurs there's also step bounded
slight variance what's the probability
that we reach some set of states within
a certain
within for example 10 steps or or less
and there's also the slight constraint
there's constrained case of
until so this is the probability that we
reach a it's a target
um and it's like before we reach set the
target we have to
remain within some other set of states
so let's give a simple slight example so
let's select return to
our six sided um die
model which only uses a fair slight coin
so if you
i recall we start in s zero and we
so repleted the flip coins either taking
slightly upper branch
when we flip ahead and the lower branch
when we flip a
tail until we reach one of the final
states and that gives us
the value of a slight die so one thing
that we could ask which is part of
showing
that the algorithm is this model is
are correct is that the probability that
we
um see a4 this should be one
slide six if this is a correct model of
a
a die so what um
the event that we want to consider so
the probability of here
this is all possible ways that we can
reach this
state here so let's have a look at this
okay
so how can we reach this state here well
there's first of all that's this
direct path which means that we throw a
tail then a head and a head
so this is obviously that's three coin
it's like so flips there are so effects
that's a half
to the power three or we could first
take this
lower loop slap once so we throw a tail
a tail
a tail and then we throw a head stuck
twice
so that corresponds to a half to the
five or we could do this loop
so twice so that we would first throw a
tail
five times and then ahead slow slope
twice
so that's a half to the seven and if we
continue then we get an infinite sum
that we can
simply work out does indeed gives us the
probability 1
6. however so computing an
infinite sum is obviously not going to
be feasible in our practice
so we can alternatively
we can calculate set the reachability so
probabilities
using a linear equation slight system
and this calculates the probabilities
for all states
of the dcmc simultaneously so let's use
xs to denote the probability of reaching
some target t when we start from this
state s
and there are three different cases to
i'll consider
so first of all if we're if s is in
other target set then we've already
reached so set the target so obviously
the probability
it is one so the second
case is if from this state s we cannot
get to
other targets so there's no path that
goes to so the target or the target's
not
it's like reachable then obviously the
probability is
zero as we just can't
just like get there and then in just
like the final case
we the probability is like select
defined
it's like recursively using the
transition
select probability so what should we do
here we look at
all possible successor states
and for each one so we take a
sum and it's the probability that we go
to some
successor state s prime multiplied by
from that successor state s s prime we
reach
the target set t so let's see
um now we could alternatively
as i consider set probabilistic
select reachability computation as a
least fixed point
computation over probability vectors
which are over the states of the our
dtmc
so if we can consider it's like the
function f
that given a um vector of
probabilities that returns eight it's a
vector of
probabilities where for some state s
the resulting probability is one
if if the state is in select the target
and
it's like otherwise it's a sum
over all such states in the are dtmc
and it's so the probability that we go
from
s to s sub prime and then it's
set the probability in it's like the
vector
slope y now if we use this
slope function and we start from the
vector of
probabilities where all um all are
zero and and we so repeatedly
so so reply apply this function f
then so we actually have that this is
this forms a um increasing
sequence of probability
slope vectors so this is this is
it's like point wise so each for
so any state um so the probability in
this vector is less than or equal to the
corresponding step probability
for the state and looks like this one
and
so like so on we also have
that the reachability so probabilities
are
it's like it's like the limit of um
these
are vectors and
um so the reachability
set probabilities are in are actually
the least
fixed point of this function f
so let's give an example
that uses the linear equation
system so let's go back to our
um die example and use
um the linear
and let's find some probability so again
that we end up in the state
corresponding to throwing a
slap four so let's go through slightly
different
our cases so there's only once
um one state in our our target
so we set select the probability here so
if if s is in
the target then we set xs to be one so
we set x4 to be like one
okay if so the target isn't
it's like reachable then we set the
probability
to be zero
so all of these states here cannot reach
this state so we set
um xs to be
zero for all of these states here s
and then for the our remaining ones we
use this so recursive
our definition here so for s
so zero it's a half times
um x of s1 which we've already said is
slope zero plus one half times
um x of s of two similarly for s2
so we either go to s5 or we go to s6
so it's a half times s5 plus a half
times x6
for s5 then it's
a half times one as obviously this is so
the target set
plus a half time it's like it's like
zero and
so on so if we simplify that
then we can substitute
um s5 and s6
it into the
formula for sm2 and
if we then select simplify and select
simplify
again then we get that s of x of s2 is
one-third
and then we can substitute this into
x of s it's like zero and we do
indeed um get that x of s
zero is one sixth or so the
probability of tossing a four is indeed
one slit six
so let's also look at at the
slight computation as a least
fixed point so here we would start with
a a vector where they're all
like zeros and then we would repeatedly
so just like so apply this select
function here
now if we do this then we see so this is
just so
the probability for state s
so zero so here we can see that it takes
a
it's a few steps to b is like greater
than
so zero but after about ten
so let's um select iterations it's
starting
to converge to one slot six
okay so just to say something on the our
complexity of
it's like computing it's like
reachability so probabilities
so there's two steps to it so so we need
to do
so the graph paste slap r so
if um it's like we use
the linear equation system
approach so we first have to find the
states that can
or the states that cannot reach the arc
target
and then we would need to solve a a
linear
equation system for the graph based
so analysis this is linear in the size
of the
our dtmc it's just a simple backwards
it's like traversal to find all of the
states
that can reach the target so we start
with a
our target state and then we find all
the ones that can reach
set the target so within so one step and
then two steps
and we keep iterating until this um set
of states
doesn't select change and then we need
to solve this system of
linear slot equations and this is
polynomial or cubic in the size of the
of dtmc so for example we can use
gaussian elimination
however in some practice
it's like iterative select methods are
it's like used for example as we showed
using
um when it's like computing it as a
least fixed point
and
so at least fixed point slight approach
corresponds to the power
method but there's more it's that
efficient
it's like methods that aren't guaranteed
to
converge such as gauss seidel
okay so just to say that we can consider
more
general probabilistic slap properties
for example we can compute the
probability that an ltl
it's like formula is um true
so in some predicate
a logic it would be of it's like this
form so this is asking what's the
probability
that the formula um site holds
so here so we would need to compute
um the setup so we'd find
set of parts which satisfy
psi and then we'd find some probability
for this set of
up paths now it's been shown that such
sets of paths are are measurable or
are it's like some elements of the
slight event set and therefore these
probabilities
are so well are defined so
just to give you a high level overview
on how this
would be done so if we're given some ltl
specification psi so you'd first
generate a deterministic
rabine automata for the ltl
slot property so one way of
doing this is to first build a
non-deterministic
it's like bookie automata and then
convert the this
spooky automata into a
deterministic rabine automaton
after that we then construct a product
our dtmc of the original
or dtmc that we want to compute so the
probabilities for
and this automator then we
identified it are accepting
um autumn strongly it's like connected
our components so these are sets of
states
such that any any state can be reached
by
any other state in the set so we've got
set of states given any two states in
the sec
there is a path
between the two and also once we enter
this
set of states then we can't just like
leave them
and then so finally we just
it's like compute reachability our
probability so
so we need to compute the probability
that we reach
these accepting um bottom strongly
subconnected components
okay so in the final video in
this part i will move on to rewards and
expected
reachability for dtm series